Bonjour et bienvenue dans Chroniques de Prof,
l'émission dans laquelle je vais m'efforcer de vous faire comprendre l'histoire,
cette immense oeuvre, toujours en cours d'écriture,
à travers moults exemples et blagues plus ou moins réussies.
Pour ce premier épisode je voulais vous parler d'un épic fail militaire que je trouve très drôle, et qui s'est passé au XIVe siècle.
Malheureusement cet événement étant lié à la guerre de Cent Ans, je ne peux pas vous le raconter
sans résumer d'abord cette guerre, ses enjeux, ses conséquences terribles...
Tous les professeurs d'histoire vous le diront, il est quasiment impossible de résumer la guerre de Cent Ans en moins de 10 minutes.
Mais comme je ne suis pas techniquement prof et que j'aime les défis: ALLONS-Y!
Et c'est parti pour la guerre de Cent Ans.
Oui enfin en réalité elle dure plutôt 116 ans, mais c'est comme si je disais que les jeux olympiques ont débuté à Olympie
ou que la guerre de Six Jours a duré six jours! WAIT...
D'abord, les causes !
Eh bien tout commence avec la mort du roi de France Charles IV le Bel!
qui est le fils de Philippe le Bel, dont on peut retenir que c'est lui qui était impliqué dans le procès des templiers.
Qui n'ont pas brûlé en slip...
Voilà, c'est mieux.
Charles IV devient roi en 1322 à la suite de son frère mort sans héritiers, et meurt à son tour en 1328.
Le roi est mort, vive....
Ben, on ne sait pas trop qui, en fait.
Charles IV est mort sans héritier mâle, il avait bien laissé sa femme enceinte avant de mourir mais manque de bol, c'est une fille qui est née!
Et je ne sais pas pourquoi on rechigne à laisser le pouvoir à une femme, ça m'échappe.
Bref, en 1328 c'est le bordel et trois personnes se dévouent bien pour prendre la couronne mais comme ils sont très polis ils passent leur temps à se refiler le bébé
Non, c'est toi qui doit régner !
Mais non, je ne suis pas digne!
Non, je déconne, ils se mettent sur la gueule.
Finalement on décide que ce sera Philippe de Valois qui régnera!
Je vous préviens, dans cette histoire, on va bouffer du Charles et du Philippe, dans le top 2 des prénoms les plus à la mode au XIV-XVe siècle!
on peut oublier le deuxième candidat,
en apprenant qu'il ne sera pas roi, il se contente de dire «Okay, peace men!»
Par contre le 3e candidat, dont je n'ai pas encore parlé, est un anglois, un rosbiff,
un obladi - oblada: Edouard III d'Angleterre.
Petit fils de Philippe le Bel par sa mère.
Edouard III est déçu, frustré, trahi.
Il se retranche chez lui pendant neuf ans pour préparer sa vengeance en caressant son chat avec un rire machiavélique,
Et en 1337: c'est la guerre !
Il envoie un de ses archevêques à Paris et balance son gant aux pieds de «Philippe qui se dit roi de France»!
Donc ça y est là, il a balancé son gant OK, ça déconne plus! C'est l'heure des batailles navales, des affrontements, des pillages!
Philippe de Valois a plus de bateaux, et il décide de s'en servir pour imposer un blocus commercial entre l'Angleterre et la France.
Comme la fédération du commerce, oui.
Et vous savez comment termine la fédération du commerce.
Bon, dans Star Wars le blocus est levé parce que les neimoidiens «un peu cons»
ont placé le générateur qui alimente touuute leur flotte dans l'entrée de leur vaisseau principal.
Est-ce que les français peuvent faire pire que ça?
Oui !
C'est ça dont je voulais vous parler, l'EPIC FAIL, qui me fait tellement rire, même s'il  devrait plutôt me faire pleurer.
La bataille de l'Ecluse a lieu dans ce qui est aujourd'hui la Belgique une fois
et la flotte française est rassemblée face au port prête à affronter les anglais qui arrivent.
Et comment les français vont-ils se déployer pour prendre l'avantage?
Ils vont enchaîner tous leurs bateaux les uns aux autres!
Un mur. De bateaux. Sur l'eau.
My god! Comment venir à bout de ce mur de bateaux totalement immobilisé?
Vous ne passerez pas !
(cris d'agonie)
Bon, ils n'ont pas utilisé le feu.
A la place les anglais ont couvert de flèches l'ensemble des navires immobilisés,
et sont montés à l'abordage pour massacrer  les français qui n'ont eu d'autre choix que de se jeter à l'eau
pour tenter de survivre en agitant leurs petites cuisses de grenouilles.
Bilan: 15 000 morts et une flotte française presque entièrement détruite.
(We are the champions)
Et ils resteront les champions un bon moment, ces mangeurs de gelée.
J'adore l'Angleterre, ne me jugez pas.
Bref, suite à cette victoire, Edouard III va les enchaîner (les victoires, pas les français).
l réussit à annexer Calais, il ruine complètement la France parce que la guerre, ça coûte cher,
et en 1356, lors de la bataille de Poitiers il capture le roi de France Jean le Bon (ce cochon) qui avait succédé à Philippe, si vous suivez toujours.
Il a gagné la première manche, les français paient une rançon énorme
(deux ans des recettes du pays, de quoi plomber leur PIB) et ils perdent environ 1/3 du territoire.
Quelques années plus tard le fils de Jean le Bon monte sur le trône, Charles V le Sage,
il commence à reconquérir les terres perdues par son papa, et il y arrive!
Tout va bien alors, elle a duré quoi, trente ans cette guerre?
J'suis déçue, on m'avait vendu un peu mieux que ça.
Que nenni! Car l'heure est maintenant à la guerre civile!
Charles VI est malade, et un peu fou, il n'y a qu'à voir son portrait d'émo dépressif pour en être persuadé.
Et c'est là qu'entrent en scène les Bourguignons qui prennent assez vite leur indépendance vis à vis de la France,
ils assassinent le duc d'Orléans parce qu'ils l'aimaient pas
et on devine déjà une petite attirance envers les anglais
(rien de sexuel là dedans).
En 1415, la bataille d'Azincourt!
Bien plus célèbre que la bataille de l'Ecluse dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure mais pas plus glorieuse,
puisque avec un rapport de force de 3 contre 1 les français arrivent à perdre.
Lamentablement.
Ça serait long de rentrer dans les détails mais les anglais avaient de très bons arcs et les français de petits chevaux qui pataugeaient dans la boue.
C'est un carnage pour l'armée française, Henry V (roi d'angleterre) ne fait pas de prisonniers,
ils sont tous exécutés.
Des milliers de nobles français meurent, on peut dire que dans la plupart des familles nobles françaises quelqu'un est mort à Azincourt.
Si toi aussi ton ancêtre est mort à Azincourt!
Côté anglais j'ai lu 13 chevaliers morts mais c'était sur wikipédia.
Que ce soit exact ou pas, 13 contre 6000, ça fait mal.
Après ça les bourguignons rejoignent franchement le côté anglais, et à leur place j'aurais fait pareil.
Je fais ici une petite parenthèse sur les bourguignons parce qu'il ne faut pas croire que ce sont juste des ducs,
quelque part en France: non, les bourguignons sont forts
et sur environ un siècle, au XVe, ils fondent ce qu'on peut appeler l’État bourguignon.
Ils sont indépendants du royaume de France, ils font ce qu'ils veulent, like a boss.
Je ne suis pas bourguignonne, mais je suis du Nord et sachez que les Flandres au XVe siècle
font également partie de l'Etat Bourguignon, Lille compris.
J'en parle parce qu'ils jouent un rôle trèèèèès important à cette période,
et vous avez sûrement déjà entendu leurs noms sans forcément savoir qui ils étaient:
Philippe le Hardi, Jean sans Peur, Philippe le Bon et Charles le Téméraire.
Après la mort de Charles le Téméraire, le duché de Bourgogne repasse dans le royaume de France,
mais avant ça ils représentaient une sorte de force d'opposition par rapport au roi de France, un peu comme la grenouille qui voulait se faire plus grosse que le bœuf.
Je reparlerai sûrement d'eux à l'occasion, mais voilà pour la brève présentation
et si vous êtes tombés sous le charme de cette famille sachez qu'il existe une version de 2048 spéciale Bourgogne FTW.
Il y a des gens qui font ce genre de choses sur internet.
Bon, c'est moi qui l'ai faite. Mon mémoire me rendait folle, les bourguignons m'obsédaient.
Jean Sans Peur, transforme-toi !
Changeons de sujet.
Quelques années plus tard les deux rois ennemis, Henry V et Charles VI, meurent la même année,
ce qui fait que leurs deux héritiers peuvent tous les deux prétendre au trône de Fer!
Euh, je m'y perds.
Ce qui fait que leurs héritiers peuvent tous les deux prétendre au trône de France!
Et celui-ci aurait pu revenir aux anglais sans l'intervention de la Pucelle.
Mais non, pas celle-là.
La pucelle Jeanne d'Arc qui vient booster un peu le dauphin Charles VII,
ui permet de bouter les anglais hors de France,
et reçoit des remerciements très chaleureux, trop chaleureux
puisqu'il la livre aux anglais et vous connaissez la suite.
Le conflit se termine lentement mais sûrement après cet épisode,
les anglais rentrent chez eux un peu déçus
Mais ne vous inquiétez pas, ils trouveront bien d'autres occasions de se taper dessus.
On se reverra à Waterloo!
(Waterloo)
Ce premier épisode de Chroniques de Prof est maintenant terminé.
J'espère qu'il vous a plu et que vous avez appris des choses, tant qu'à faire.
N'hésitez pas à commenter, partager sur les réseaux sociaux pour instruire vos amis
et vous abonner à la chaîne parce que j'ai encore des tas de choses à vous raconter.
Enfin j'ajouterai que je ne connais pas tout sur tout donc si vous avez des corrections à apporter n'hésitez pas!
Si personne n'a de correction à apporter à cet épisode je considérerai que mon résumé de la guerre de Cent Ans est parfait.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et ne manquez pas les prochaines, à bientôt!